bonjour à tous aujourd'hui nous sommes
sûrs de la haute-savoie quario tout le
monde n'importe quoi cette intro c'est
scandaleux c'est parti en charge la
partie eau en plus on attaque tout de
suite je le jeu de mots un petit peu
lourd
allez hop on avait joué deux heures 18
aujourd'hui on va jouer 5h18 parce que
ce jeu est une [ __ ] d'horreur et
encore un jeu de mots jeux d'horreur le
jeu c'est laurent mais qu'est ce qui
nous arrive c'est fou c'est reparti au
mais du coup on reprend le lien on se
retape l'interview avec la mafia sa
poupée alors seulement on a bel et bien
finie on vient de se réveiller alors ta
joie que dalle
on s'en fou j'ai compris vous voulez pas
de savoir ce qui se passe c'est parti
alors apparemment une petite fille qui
pleure mais où est elle doit pas être
loin je l'entends un peu elle devrait
être vers la la il ya des pleurs c'est
tout près verseaules si d'autres
personnes qui pleurent carrément thuram
avec son épisode mais de quoi qu'il
arrive
allez là à l'eau pourquoi père du jeune
femme
bon il faut que je m'approche c'est ça
maintenant tu vas commencer par tourner
à l'est parce que tu commences à me
péter les couilles tu commences à me
péter du coup tu montes bon c'est
apparemment aussi je te pète elle est
cool du coup elle est plus là mais
qu'est ce qui met barre toi
elle passe en mode binaire et j'te
défonce ok je fais des headshots avec
mon appareil photo direct à l'écrit
christ krill tu cries tu cries tu cries
sur ada fac on fera qui te plaît avec
son corps de foetus qui vole on va
l'exposer direct j'ai eu vous avez vu
j'ai fait un quick scope à skis pour la
couronne shapatava mais regardez ce
serait aussi inquiété
bref un chien commence à m e sous moi je
veux voir les copines je leur dit
écoutez ya un foetus qui vole qui me
suit lp mais [ __ ] mais regardez où ça
c'est scandaleux par toi vas t'en as ben
voila quand même à gauche médias ou
d'haïti est ça qui est une sorte de
pokédex version fantôme c'est assez
glauque et ce qu'elle protégeait
l'entrée secrète menant un trésor très
secret pas du tout la porte est fermée
de chez fermé en parle à messieurs dames
regardez au fait le tour peter ne les
pros demi tour les filles vous devinerez
jamais ce qui s'est passé je n'ai pas
réussi à ouvrir ses portes
bassolé copine en hausse et matic
incroyable or je sens la qualité avant
tout un téléphone par terre à bon dieu l
a vu quoi elle a vu quoi qu'est ce qui
se passe assez mes potes à nickel donc
c'était bel et bien la réaction elles
sont juste des cds quoi tu avais pas
tout le monde demain autour de moi c'est
ça c'est la position c'est le bad
je vais pas glisser par un violon
actuellement c'est très désagréable oh
là bas il ya un temps pour regarder on
va y aller on va se faire violer des
quatre ans jamais dit qu'il dit lui
d'arrêter
on en a connu les orchestres fou mais
celui là il est quand même vraiment fou
quoi qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
des têtes ça dégage ce à quoi je crois
et photos puis retour avec la tête de ma
grand-mère dans mes mains quoi
franchement ya un problème avec ce jeu
allait ouvre toi
à cinématique à dans le chargement un
monde où un palace va jamais dit j'avais
alors y'a pas un petit fantôme qui garde
le palace 1
par exemple on fait tout ce qui vole n'y
a pas ça n'existe pas bon alors on
continue il faut une clé apparemment
pourrir le cadenas et rien du tout quoi
oh mon dieu mais si ces deux portes avec
pas de cadenas [ __ ] et là c'est
l'agression
oh là où là on le sait ça sent toujours
pas bon pas eu dans tous les jeux à un
loclois voilà je l'avais dit j'avais des
[ __ ] alors on prend nos esprits qui
protège donc ce couloir je t'attends
respirer mon enfant tu as des problèmes
de peau - bonjour il n'y a rien du tout
on va marcher comme ça aille un miroir
là-bas en fait je m'en bats les steaks
je veux dire je mettrais un coup de tête
ok elle m'a stoppé direct et un truc
dans moi regardez par exemple j'aime
voir à habas je vais pas moi je suis
mort mais à mon avis un démon qui est
devant moi vous savez la tête qu'on est
dans les mains tout à l'heure on a crié
à fait au point d'en profiter
regardez 11 voilà à voile a jamais dit
quoi m et je suis trop fort je suis
scénariste va t'en va t'en dit early
papon elle s'amuse ça ne fait pas du
tout rire quand je ferai une photo
direct là dedans à lui qu'est ce tu bats
affaires question fois quittait la casse
et le miroir bureau un petit pas de
cassage de mayroy en plein vote médaille
mais laisse moi te vas t'en direct
direct
oh merde à mai par toi là ça suffit on a
fini de jouer [ __ ] je t'ai fait le tir
lui pardon tu t'en vas
telle époque mais tais-toi déjà dans un
premier temps un kit a autorisé à parler
comme ça ici à mon dieu on arrive dans
un endroit où c'est beau on va ouvrir ça
on peut pas à peut-être que mec qui joue
du violon il se cache pas avoir regardé
le cheat
bonjour je ne peux pas rentrer mais je
vois tout juste une paroi route et
s'était ouvert [ __ ] je croyais jamais
trouvé un truc de ouf et ou pas du tout
celle fille à l'ancienne on aille a pas
encore une caméra frontale
la hyène porte à ça va même manquer ses
effets spéciaux dignes d'iron man 3 et 2
et 1 réunit sa part sur un piano aller
sa part sur un court je me suis agressée
par une planche quoi elle chantait un
fantôme là ah ok je me tiens ça craint
trop ici
bon ça ok je veux agressé par un micro
un mondiaux il ya une force démoniaque
que je ne peux pas voir par contre je me
barre de aux plats à les betis
combattants mais qu'est-ce qui est lente
et la nourriture mais tu vas te calmer
un si tu veux accéder aux puf et attend
comme tout le monde
oh c'était tout près là actuellement je
fais un break à culottes un véritable le
vrai regardez moi ça odieux hop la 3g le
ya une sauvegarde automatique je lui
prochaine fois tu essaieras pas de me
voler mon poulet grillé biatch c'est ici
qu'une scène effroyable a eu lieu au
pelage bobards j'arrive lots alors c'est
quoi ici quel est ce lieu lieu construit
en 1788 d'après la richissime sekloka on
dirait que des miroirs alors pas du tout
on peut à il ya un objet la ramasser
avec une énergie mystérieuse
oui une clé la clé du placard réduction
totalement erronée lité voir un objet
que j'ai tout oublié au bon d'amélia
deux secondes c'est pas du tout un
miroir au népal on est venu de là bas là
mais du coup je savais qu'ils allaient
se passer un truc bizarre comme ça elle
ne regardez pas comme ça et peluches âge
vous défonce tout ça elle veut plus
prendre de photos d'eux ont mimé surimi
roi hassan ii la migraine a really à une
énigme c'est sûr mais peut-être miroir
hamas et celui là
je ferai truc on pique sa norma passe
plainte doit pas se plaindre voilà le
hasard a bien fait les choses finalement
où est donc la drum ladder et maintenant
débrouillez ouais on a trouvé le douala
soum
c'est à partir en couille oh oh mon dieu
barre toi bats toi barre toi là mais je
te prends en photo au plein matin je
suis armé d'un respawn mon gars ok t'as
pas lire et soigne pas de soucis j'étais
au plafond en fait c'est ça tu es là où
aller dtc en fait je veux regarder là où
elle est et ensuite je vais à
photographier mes patins le miroir voilà
c'est compliqué ça lui par exemple elle
est là elle est là elle a à les démons
de l'enfer va tant elle est où la conne
à elle été un non elle était dans un
coin mais vase une mais vas-y mais viol
viol mois devant tant que jean vas-y
bref il ya des salles comme on perçoit
surtout tout seul mec c'est bon c'est
fini
oui ah là là c'était très chiant la
prochaine fois je propose que tu pètes
le miroir directement avec un marteau
sert à beaucoup plus vite j'arrive pour
prendre le thé avec un fort taux
maintenant c'est comme s'apparenter à il
ya un petit moment allez pouvoir
m'asseoir bas mais qu'est ce que j'ai
dit en plus à l'est ces mois d'été
fantôme je peux juste regarder à gauche
et devant moi à elles prennent forme
très mignonne alors qu'elle paye tout
mignonne est ce que je vois ça m'a aussi
au début mais en si gros plan il faut
toujours se méfier du corps attention
conseil de haut la gelée des cirques et
si vous avez dit toujours se méfier du
corps c'est une règle de base j'ai vu
tout vrai visage tu ferais attention
quand même à elle fait un petit massage
avant d'avandonner lutte et finalement
on le sait on l'a compris ah je
m'embrouille auquel et le fuck je
m'attire moi même de l'autre côté à les
grilles on savait qu'on aime c'est les
fameux après chaque chargement via les
grilles on sait maintenant je me barre
je me tire je me tiens cet endroit ça y
est c'est la femme doubt à cécile
vannier fait apparemment les avez la
flemme de faire une cinématique de plus
a pourtant ils sont tellement bien en
cinématique assez stylé quand même c'est
des jolis dessins et loris pasqua à la
police la retrouve
elle est très mal en point la note perso
on lui met une petite couverture sur
pattes et apparemment donc allé fort
déçu et la police la ramène chez elle
c'est comme la bohème et elle est de
l'autre côté du miroir donc tout est
fake
regardez là il va se passer une couche
je le sais c'est absolument faux tout ce
qui se passe
en plein voilà et j'ai bien dit elle va
me suivre jusqu'à la fin même si je suis
parti de l'endroit c'est ça qui se passe
oui mais voilà jean pierre frencel des
vidéos cette deuxième sur twitter
j'espère que ça vous a plu
il n'y avait pas trop de cinématiques
épique cette fois une go m qui était
hors du commun
du lourd n'était pas aimé la vidéo ça
vous a plu à mater l'ancien épisode si
vous l'avez pas vu dans le cas où
quelqu'un vous aurez absolument rien
compris à cette vidéo d'ailleurs on se
retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo tu as tout le monde merci au
regard des pis aller pratiquer
applicatifs fatih atik ça supporte enfin
tu dois faire jour